it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we have two things we have some
items and we have some exclusive
discounts all right so start shopping
now scan the QR code on your screen go
ahead and do it or visit cbsdeals.com
let's get right to it lifestyle host
Gail bass is in the house so we have a
product yes that could make us a little
bit more comfortable while we fly yeah
you know what it's like to fly with
three kids and you know what it's like
worrying about the germs on the plane
because you know they've done study
after study and basically this is the
dirtiest part of the tray table the tray
table not the bathroom so if you're
traveling with your kids or just with
your stuff the airplane pockets is the
thing you want to do okay you think you
want to take when you travel what's
great is it can hold all your stuff here
you can see it's holding a water bottle
some fruit your note cards but let's say
you're traveling with your kids you
could have their crayons their tablets
their screens their everything
everything in there and then you could
grab it with you stuff it in your
carry-on and not forget it in there you
can see it sits on your airplane tray
this these are built for coach seats so
and they have they're made of polyester
and spandex so they're stretched to fit
they stretch the fish tray table yes yes
so so you can lay it down and just eat
right on top of it because it's clean
yes you don't have to worry about that
and it's washable you just wash it yeah
and also with the great price are
cbsdeals.com
19.99 so you know peace of mind when
you're traveling something for the whole
family because I almost left my tablet
the other day when I was sitting in the
bulkhead I want to do that right you
don't worry about that all right so uh
summer's coming up good time for sports
these are great summer deals and I love
this this is City bonfires this was
created by Two Dads who were impacted by
their jobs were impacted by the pandemic
these are made in America and these are
delicious they're uh they have a s'mores
kid but it's the city bonfires this
right here you could take the fire with
you it's portable it's made for use
outside only and when you light this up
it lasts for three to five hours it's
soy but it's also food grade so you
could roast your s'mores by this and if
you look right here you could see how
you have the family by the fire this is
the table in my boyfriend's backyard we
had a little date night in the backyard
with that hey you got to do what you got
to do today romance alive and then we
had dessert right there already made for
you okay easy peasy I love the prices on
this they start at
28.95
hot outside
yeah Americans are chronically
dehydrated we don't drink enough you
need to have a half gallon of water
today from every athlete we have the
drink bottle and what I love about this
is not only does it have a thermal cover
and it has it protects the tip so it
keeps dust off of it everywhere it has
pockets for days you could put your cell
phone in there you could put maybe some
earbuds in there so you don't lose them
people lose their earbuds and then
sometimes you can even have your keys in
there because it has it has a it has a
carabiner for your keys but you could
take it off because look right here if
you look on the side it has the times a
day you need to swallow it reminds you
like from like look here from 10 to 11
you might have forgotten to drink your
water so it helps keep you hydrated half
gallon size I love this the price on
this one 63 off
29.99 oh and I love the work earbuds
from raycon these are from Ray J
Brandy's brother he knows music and you
know what he and Rayleigh the creators
wanted to create an earbud that had
great quality that didn't cost everybody
a lot of money we have these for 79.99
they come with different gel tips to fit
your ears hurt all day yeah and they
stay in they stay in you do the gel tips
that fit you what's the price on that
79.97 that's good man shout out to Ray J
still doing this thing after all these
years all right Gail bass we appreciate
you of course we partner with all these
companies to get these deals to buy
anything that you saw scan the QR code
on your screen or head over to
cbsdeals.com to start shopping now for
any of these products and many more we
will be right back